Newton's first law tells us about the
motion of isolated bodies by an isolated
body we mean one on which the net force
is zero one that's isolated from all
interactions to as great a degree as
possible Newton's first law states that
an isolated body moves in a straight
line at constant velocity and will
continue to do so as long as it remains
undisturbed note that that constant
velocity might be zero so for example a
body at rest an isolated body at rest
will remain at rest if left undisturbed
an isolated body moving at constant
velocity will continue to move at
constant velocity as long as it remains
undisturbed it turns out that it's
always possible to define a coordinate
system in which an isolated body moves
at constant velocity perhaps zero such a
coordinate system is called an inertial
coordinate system so another way of
stating Newton's first law is that
inertial coordinate systems exist now
it's worth pointing out that not all
useful coordinate systems are inertial
the ones that are we call non inertial
coordinate systems as an example imagine
that I'm standing in an elevator that's
accelerating upward if we defined a
coordinate system that moves with the
elevator that coordinate system is
accelerated with respect to an observer
who is at rest in that accelerated
coordinate system an isolated body would
not move at constant velocity so there
are applications where using non
inertial coordinate systems or is
convenient however in this course we
will concentrate on inertial coordinate
systems in which isolated bodies move at
constant velocity what if the body is
not isolated if a force acts on a body
then it will accelerate in proportion to
that force in particular for a point
like constant mass Newton's second law
tells us that the vector force is equal
to the mass times the vector
acceleration so in other words the
acceleration caused by a force is
proportional to that force and the
constant of proportionality is the mass
now there are two important points I
want to make about you
and second law the first is that forces
always involve real physical
interactions something must be acting on
the object if nothing is acting on the
object if the object is isolated then we
know from Newton's first law that an
isolated body never accelerates in an
inertial frame it moves at constant
velocity so the only way to have an
object move with the velocity that's
changing that is to have an acceleration
is to have a force acting on it and
Newton's second law tells us exactly how
that works the second point I want to
make is that this statement of Newton's
second law F equals MA is actually a
special case it's for the special case
of a constant point like mass more
generally Newton's second law is written
as the force is equal to the time
derivative of the momentum P now we'll
talk about the mentor later in this
course in more detail but I'll just tell
you that the momentum for a point like
mass is defined as the mass times the
velocity now for a point mass that's
constant these two equations are exactly
identical if you take the derivative of
M times V where m is a constant you just
get M times the vector a and you you get
the first equation back so it's just a
fancier way of writing the same thing it
doesn't convey any new information so so
why do we talk about this as being the
more general form it's because this
second form of Newton's second law can
be generalized to a system of particles
or a system where mass is flowing in the
mass of something is changing you can't
describe that but F equals MA but it's
always true that for a given system F
equals DP DT and we'll see how that
works and more complicated mass flow
problems later in the course